สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 13
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 12
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 14
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ก็ได้ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 8 โมง
8 โมงกี่นาที
2 นาทีค่ะ
8 โมง 2 นาทีก็เป็นเวลาเช้า 8 โมงเช้านะ
คะครูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้าหรือยัง
ครูฟ้ายังไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าค่ะคุณหญิง
หงิงๆๆ
หิวหรอคะยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้านี่ 8 โมง
แล้วนะ
8 โมงแล้วหรอ
[เพลง]
กินแล้วค่ะ
ทุกคนกินข้าวเช้ากี่โมงคะทุกคนกินข้าว
เช้าน่าจะ 7 โมงหรือไม่ก็แบบ 8 โมงไหม
ข้าวเช้าอ่ะ
คนไทยนะ
ใช่ค่ะก็เมื่อก่อนคนไทยกินอะไรก็ได้เป็น
ข้าวเช้าอยากกินอะไรก็กินใช่ไหมคะแต่ตอน
นี้ก็อาจจะแค่ดื่มกาแฟ
กาแฟร้อน 1 แก้วขนมปัง
เป็นอาหารเช้า
ใช่ค่ะแต่กินอะไรส่วนใหญ่อ่ะคนไทยก็จะไม่
กินอาหารที่มันเผ็ดๆตอนเช้านะจริงหรอผู้
หญิงคือฟ้าอยากกิน
เขาจะกินอะไรคะ
จริงๆนะ
คะผู้หญิง
คะครูฟ้ากินส้มตำตอนเช้าเนี่ยนะครูฟ้า
ตื่นนอนมาล้างหน้าแปรงฟันแล้วก็กินส้มตำ
ตอนเช้าครูฟ้าโอเคหรอท้องโอเคหรอ
มันเผ็ดนะคะมันมีพริกใช่ไหมเนี่ยมีพริก
อันนี้พริกหรอคะ
ตายค่ะพริกพริก
ใช่ครูฟ้ากินส้มตำเนี่ยอาจจะกินพริก 1
เม็ด 2 เม็ด 3 เม็ด 4 เม็ด 5 เม็ด 6 เม็ด
7 เม็ด 8 เม็ด 9 เม็ด 10 เม็ด
ส้มตำใส่พริก 10 เม็ดตอนเช้า
มันเผ็ดมากครูฟ้าก็โอเคหรอ
เผ็ดจริงๆค่ะ
โอเคไหมอ่ะ
ใช่ไม่โอเคไม่ได้ไม่ใช้
กินไม่ได้ด้วยใช่ไหม
แต่ถ้าเป็นตอนเที่ยงเนาะตอนกลางวันนะคะ
หรือว่าอาหารเย็น
6 โมงเย็นเนี่ยโอเค
แต่เผ็ดมากๆก็ไม่โอเคนะ
เผ็ดมากๆก็ไม่ดีหรอคะผู้หญิงทำไมอ่ะปวด
ท้องอยู่นะแบบ
เพราะว่าคนไทยจะคืออาหารไทยเนี่ยเผ็ดใช่
ไหมคะครูฟ้าส่วนใหญ่เนาะนักเรียนอาจจะคิด
ว่าอุ๊ยมาประเทศไทยชอบกินอาหารไทยแต่ว่า
อาหารไทยเนี่ยมันเผ็ดมากๆเพราะว่าอาหาร
ไทยเนี่ยจะใส่พริกมีพริกเยอะๆแล้วก็คิด
ว่าอาหารของนักเรียนอาจจะเผ็ดน้อยกว่าคือ
ถ้านักเรียนเป็นคนยุโรปคนอเมริกานะคะแต่
ว่าถ้าเป็นคน
ลาวกัมพูชาเมียนมาร์เวียดนามเกาหลีคนจีน
ก็อาจจะกินเผ็ดได้มากกว่าคนยุโรปคน
อเมริกาคือพริกเนี่ยเป็น
เพราะว่าเม็ดพริกหรือว่าอันนี้เองนะครู
ฟ้าเม็ดพริกหรือว่าอันนี้บีไส้ของพริกคุณ
ฟ้าคิดว่าพริกเห็ดจากอะไรเม็ดพริกหรือว่า
ไส้ของพริกเนี่ยตรงนี้ดี
คิดว่า a ค่ะ
เม็ดพริกหรอ
เม็ดพริก
ไม่ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าทำไมอ่ะผู้หญิงเม็ดพริกก็
เผ็ดนะ
ก็เผ็ดค่ะแต่ที่ทำให้เราเผ็ดมากๆเลยเนี่ย
ก็คือนี่แหละ
ไส้ของมันเนี่ยแหละค่ะถ้านักเรียนอยากกิน
พริกแต่กลัวเผ็ดก็เอาไส้ออกก็ได้นะคะ
ไม่ได้สิส่วนใหญ่เราจะตำใช่ไหมคนไทยก็จะ
มีแบบมีครก
แล้วก็เอาพริกเนี่ยใส่ลงไปแล้วก็มีสากกะ
เบือแล้วก็ตามๆๆก็ทั้งเม็ดพริกทั้งไส้
พริกก็รวมกันหมดก็เลยเผ็ด
ใช่ไหมคะแป๊บนึงนะ
ค่ะได้ค่ะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะพริกเผ็ดใช่ไหมอันนี้คือพริกพริกสด
นะผู้หญิงมีคำถามข้อที่ 2 ถามครูฟ้านะคะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าพริกสดอันนี้คือพริกสดนะคะ
กับพริกแห้งพริกแห้งก็คือเอาพริกเนี่ยมา
ตากแดดใช่ไหมมีแดดแล้วก็มีพริกนะคะพริก
แล้วก็เอาพริกเนี่ยตากแดดอาจจะ 1 วัน 2
วันมันก็เป็นพริกแห้งอันนี้ถามครูฟ้านะ
อันนี้ไม่รู้นะคะแล้วแต่คนสำหรับครูฟ้า
เนี่ยครูฟ้าคิดว่าพริกแห้งกับพริกสดพริก
อันไหนเห็ดมากกว่ากันเวลาครูฟ้ากินอ่ะ
คิดว่า
สำหรับครูฟ้าคิดว่าพริกสดใช่ไหมเวลาปูปลา
กินพริกสดเนี่ยจะรู้สึกเผ็ดสมมุติว่าพริก
สด 1 เม็ด 2 เม็ดแล้วก็พริกแห้ง 1 เม็ด 2
เม็ดเท่าๆกัน
พริกสดเนี่ยเผ็ดมากกว่า
[เพลง]
บางคนก็บอกว่าพริกแห้งเผ็ดมากกว่าแต่
สำหรับผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็คิดเหมือนครูฟ้านะ
คะผู้หญิงคิดว่าพริกสดเผ็ดมากกว่า
ตายค่ะแต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยมันไม่ได้แค่
ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะที่มีพริกเนาะ
เม็กซิโกะเม็กซิโกก็กินเผ็ดไหมคะ
ใช่ไหม
มันเหมือนไม่เหมือนอันนี้
ใช่ค่ะถ้านักเรียนดู
ขิงขยายให้นะคะเอ้า
นี่ไง
พริกที่เขาบอกว่าเห็ดที่สุดในโลกเลยอัน
นี้พริกแบบคนไทยนะคะพริกขี้หนูในไทยเนี่ย
เผ็ดมากๆแต่เขาบอกว่าพริกที่เผ็ดที่สุด
เขาเช็คมาแล้วเนี่ยนะคะก็คือพลิกอันเนี้ย
ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ลมหายใจมังกรดราก้อนบอล
ผู้หญิงไม่เคยกินนะแต่ผู้หญิงเคยกินพริก
เนี่ยพาราปินโย่เนี่ยเผ็ดมากครูฟ้าน้อง
ผู้หญิงมัน
มันกินอยู่ที่ไหนผู้หญิงในไทยมีไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงเคยซื้อในซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตแต่ถ้าครู
ฟ้าไปซื้อที่ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตคือแพงนะที่
ไทยเนี่ยแพงแต่อร่อยนะบางครั้งถ้าครูฟ้า
ไปกินไปร้าน Subway ที่ขายแซนด์วิชอ่ะค่ะ
บางครั้งเขาจะมีพาราปินโย่ด้วยแต่เขาจะ
หั่นเป็นวงกลมแบบนี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็จะมีนี่
แล้วก็มีเม็ดๆๆอย่างเงี้ยมันจะเป็นไซส์
ประมาณอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็ใส่ที่แซนด์วิช
นะคะอืม
แต่คลิกเนี่ยมันเผ็ดนะครูฟ้าชอบกินเผ็ด
ไหมล่ะคะ
คุณฟ้าชอบกินเผ็ดค่ะเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมตอน
ครูฟ้าอายุ 20
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยครูฟ้ากินเผ็ดเก่งมากๆนะ
แต่ว่าครูฟ้ากินเผ็ดเก่งชอบกินเผ็ดแต่กิน
พริกก็เผ็ดใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะกินพริกก็
เผ็ดค่ะตอนนี้แล้วเนี่ย
เผ็ดเผ็ดเผ็ดมากๆ
เออนักเรียนมาประเทศไทยก็อยากกินอาหารไทย
แต่นักเรียนก็อาจจะคิดว่าโอ๊ยอาหารไทย
เผ็ดมากมันไม่โอเคครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็เป็นคนกิน
เผ็ดครูหญิงก็เป็นคนกินเผ็ดเป็นคนไทยเรา
ก็จะมีเทคนิคมาบอกนักเรียนค่ะว่าถ้าเวลา
นักเรียนกินพริกที่เผ็ดหรือว่ากินอาหาร
ไทยเผ็ดๆจะทำยังไงให้หายเผ็ดให้แบบเผ็ด
เนี่ยมันหายไปคุณฟังมีเทคนิคไว้เวลาครู
เอาที่ครูฟ้าก่อนเลย
เทคนิคของคุณฟ้าเวลาเผ็ดนะคะ
นั่งสมาธิ
นักเรียนบอกว่าโอ้โหพริกก็เผ็ดประเทศไทย
เนี่ย
มันร้อนสำหรับคนไทยประเทศไทยเนี่ย 35
องศาเซลเซียสร้อน
พริกก็เผ็ดให้นักเรียนจะแบบไม่เผ็ด
คิดว่านักเรียนตายนะคะไม่ได้ FC ถ้าเวลา
ครูฟ้าเผ็ดไงเวลาที่ครูฟ้ากรี๊ดกรี๊ดไม่
ได้กินพริกแบบหยิบพริกมากินนะคะนักเรียน
อาจจะกินส้มตำกินต้มยำกุ้งกินอาหารไทยที่
มันเผ็ดๆคือฟ้าทำยังไงให้มันเผ็ดน้อยลง
น้อยลงน้อยลงแล้วก็หายเผ็ดเลยจริงๆหวานๆ
นะสำหรับปูม้า
ก็คือกินอะไรหวานๆน่ะหรอใช่
อันนี้ได้ไหม
ใช่ไอศกรีมก็ได้ค่ะเวลาเผ็ดมากๆเนี่ยมัน
ก็ต้องไปหยิบขนมไอศกรีมอย่างนี้มากิน
อ๋อหรือว่าเค้กคุกกี้ช็อกโกแลต
ผู้หญิงคะ
อะไรคะ
อันนี้ชิวาว่าเหรอ
ยังไงอ่ะ
น้องหมา
ใช่มั้ยอันนี้ตาตาแล้วก็จมูกอันนี้
เหมือนๆๆ
งงเลยครูฟ้านี่ไม่ใช่อันนี้ไอศกรีมไงก็
เนี่ย
ไอศกรีมไม่รู้อะไรบ้างอ่ะวานิลลาช็อค
มิ้นต์หรือเปล่าอันนี้ไอศกรีมไอศกรีมหลาย
ๆรสไอศครีมเนี่ยก็หวานไง
ใช่ค่ะมันหวานนะคะซึ่ง
มันก็ดี
มันจะช่วยเวลาเราเผ็ดมากๆอืมเวลาเผ็ด
แล้วกินไอศกรีมเนี่ยครูฟ้าโอเคนะ
ใช่ค่ะเขาบอกว่าเวลาที่เราเนี่ยกินอาหาร
เผ็ดหรือว่าแบบมันเผ็ดอ่ะเผ็ดมากๆมันจะ
เผ็ดที่ปากเผ็ดที่ลิ้นใช่ไหมลิ้นของเรา
นักเรียนอาจจะแบบเหมือนมังกรเลยป่ะ
เพราะว่ามันเผ็ดมากๆเขาบอกว่ากินไอศกรีม
เนี่ยได้นะคะเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วเขาแนะนำ
ให้เรากินนมให้เราดื่มนมแต่ว่ามันต้อง
เป็นนมที่ใส่น้ำแข็งด้วยนะใส่น้ำแข็ง
กูต้องเป็นนมที่ใส่น้ำแข็งด้วยนมเย็นๆไง
ถ้าไม่ใส่น้ำแข็งก็คือนักเรียนก็ต้องเอา
นมเนี่ยใส่ในตู้เย็นใช่ไหมคะ
เอานมใส่ตู้เย็นให้มันนมมันเย็นแล้วเราก็
ดื่มนมเวลาที่เรารู้สึกแบบเห็ดมากๆเนี่ย
มันจะช่วยให้เผ็ดน้อยลงก็คือช่วยให้เรา
เนี่ยหายเผ็ดนะคะหรือว่าไอศกรีมที่ครู
หญิงบอกเพราะว่าไอศครีมเนี่ยก็มีนมใช่ไหม
แต่ไม่รู้คิดว่าอันนี้ถ้าเป็นพวก Shaw
Bay ก็เลยเรียกอะไรซอเบย์หรอ Sherbet
เออไอศกรีม Sherbet ที่ไม่มีนมอย่างนั้น
น่ะอาจจะไม่ช่วยนะคะ
ต้องเป็นไอศกรีมที่แบบใส่นม
ใช่ไหมแต่ต้องเป็นใช่ต้องเป็นไอศกรีมหรอ
กินเผ็ดใช่ไหมแล้วก็ดื่มเป๊ปซี่โคคาโคล่า
อะไรเงี้ย
ใช่มันจะช่วยให้เผ็ดน้อยลงแล้วเสร็จแล้ว
เผ็ดมากขึ้นใช่ไหม
มันเผ็ดนะคะนักเรียนแค่นักเรียนกิน
เป๊ปซี่เยอะๆนักเรียนก็ยิ่งเผ็ดนะคะใช่
ถ้านักเรียนเห็นแล้วนักเรียนดื่มน้ำดื่ม
น้ำเนี่ยดื่มน้ำใส่น้ำแข็งใช่ไหมน้ำเย็น
น่ะค่ะนักเรียนดื่มน้ำเย็นเนี่ยดื่มเข้า
ไปปุ๊บนักเรียนจะรู้ตอนที่นักเรียนดื่ม
เนี่ยไม่เผ็ดแต่พอนักเรียนดื่มไปแล้วสัก 1
วินาที 2 วินาทีนักเรียนเนี่ยจะเผ็ดมาก
ขึ้นไม่ได้เผ็ดน้อยลงได้เผ็ดมากใช่ค่ะเรา
ต้องดื่มอะไรที่เป็นพวกนมนมเนี่ยเวลาเรา
ดื่มไปแล้วเนี่ยมันจะทำให้เราเนี่ยเผ็ด
น้อยลงน้อยลงหรือว่าไอศกรีมที่เป็นนมก็ทำ
ให้เราเนี่ยเผ็ดน้อยลงและนักเรียนบอกนัก
เรียนดื่มนมไม่ได้กินไอศกรีมไม่ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนก็กินข้าวก็ได้อืมข้าวก็ช่วยนะคะ
กินข้าวยัดเข้าไปในปากเลย
ใช่ค่ะถ้านักเรียนบอกว่าฉันไม่ชอบกินข้าว
ก็ขนมปังเนี่ยกินเข้าไปนะคะ
ขนมปังโอเคนะ
อื้อ
มันๆเวลาที่ครูฟ้าเผ็ดฟ้าเคยกินขนมปัง
เข้าไปนะคะ
ก็ดีขึ้นโอเคเลย
ใช่ไหมมันจะทำให้ความเผ็ดในปากในลิ้นหรือ
ว่ารอบๆปากของเราเนี่ยมันจะทำให้เผ็ดน้อย
ลงน้อยลงแล้วก็อีกอันนึงที่ดื่มได้แล้ว
คุณหญิงคิดว่าคิดว่าด้วยนะคะคิดว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเป็นเครื่องดื่มที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบ
ดื่มเขาบอกว่าน้ำอันนี้นะคะครูฟ้ามันช่วย
ทำให้เผ็ดน้อยลงแล้วก็ดีมากด้วยอ่ะดีมาก
กว่านมด้วยนะ
อะไรอ่ะผู้หญิงน้ำมะเขือเทศ
กูฟายชอบกินน้ำมะเขือเทศนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเขารักมากนะคะน้ำมะเขือ
เทศเขาบอกว่าแต่เป็นคนดื่มไม่ได้ไงครู
หญิงเนี่ยชอบมะเขือเทศไม่ชอบน้ำมะเขือเทศ
ผู้หญิง
มะเขือเทศมากอร่อยนะ
เขาบอกว่าเวลาที่เราเผ็ดมากๆน้ำมะเขือเทศ
เนี่ยมันจะมีความเปรี้ยวนิดหน่อยไหม
มะเขือเทศมันก็เปรี้ยวนิดหน่อยใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็อาจจะเค็มๆในมะเขือเทศนั่นแหละเวลา
ที่เราดื่มเข้าไปแล้วความเปรี้ยวหรือว่า
ความเค็มของน้ำมะเขือเทศอ่ะค่ะมันจะช่วย
ลดความเผ็ดในปากของเรา
แบบนี้นี่เองฟ้าไม่รู้เลยว่ามันดื่มน้ำ
มะเขือเทศได้นะคะ
ได้ค่ะน้ำมะเขือเทศเนี่ยช่วยเราแน่ๆนะคะ
แต่ถ้านักเรียนไม่ชอบดื่มน้ำมะเขือเทศ
เจ้านักเรียนเผ็ดมากๆใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนแบบ
เผ็ดๆแล้วก็มีน้ำมะเขือเทศแต่นักเรียนไม่
ชอบ
ดื่มน้ำมะเขือเทศเท่านั้นมันไม่ใช่ช้อยส์
แบบว่า 1 ช้อยส์นะใช่มันไม่ได้แบบว่าน้ำ
มะเขือเทศคือดีที่สุดที่จะทำให้เราเผ็ด
น้อยลงไงมันก็จะมีอีกน้ำนึงนะคะก็คือน้ำ
มะนาว
นักเรียนแต่ต้องเป็นใช่ค่ะต้องเป็นน้ำ
มะนาวแบบว่ามะนาวมะนาวมะนาวอ่ะอื้อหือ
มะนาวมะนาวมะนาวคืออะไร
ต้องเป็นมะนาวสมมุติว่ามีมะนาวสัก 90%
อย่างนี้ค่ะในน้ำมะนาวแล้วก็อาจจะใส่
เกลือก็ได้ไหมเกลือก็คือ
เกลือเนี่ยมันจะเค็มๆใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนจะ
เอาไว้โรยใส่ในเฟรนช์ฟรายอ่ะเกลือเค็มๆ
เพราะว่าน้ำมะนาวกับเกลือคือถ้านักเรียน
ดื่มน้ำมะนาว 100% เลยอ่ะเพียวๆอ่ะ
ไม่ได้นะคะแสบคอก็จะมีน้ำมะนาวใช่ไหมอาจ
จะเป็นน้ำมะนาวแล้วนักเรียนก็ใส่เกลือลง
ไปคนๆแล้วก็ใส่น้ำใส่เขาก็ไม่เขาอาจจะให้
ใส่โซดาไหม
น้ำก็ได้แต่ว่าน้ำมันทำให้เราเผ็ดมากขึ้น
ไงน้ำเปล่าอ่ะนะ
เขาบอกว่าความเปรี้ยวเพราะว่ามะนาวเนี่ย
มันจะเปรี้ยวใช่ไหมคะอืมๆเปรี้ยวของมะนาว
เนี่ยมันจะทำให้เราเนี่ยเผ็ดน้อยลง
ที่ครูหญิงบอกมาไม่ใช่นักเรียนดื่มน้ำ
มะนาวเสร็จนักเรียนจะหายเผ็ด 100% นะคะ
แต่มันทำให้คุ้มเนี่ยเผ็ดน้อยลงน้อยลง
น้อยลงดื่มน้ำมะนาวดื่มน้ำมะเขือเทศอัน
นี้ได้นะคะแต่แค่ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบผู้หญิงก็
เลยไม่ใส่หัวใจ
นะคะกินขนมปัง
กินข้าวเออแต่ผู้หญิงเคยเผ็ดแล้วก็กิน
ข้าวอ่ะยัดๆเข้าไปนะคะคือบางทีเร็วๆอ่ะ
คือต้องกินเป็นคำใหญ่ๆนะคะนักเรียนขนมปัง
ก็เหมือนกันนะนักเรียนต้องเอาแบบคำใหญ่ๆ
แล้วก็ใส่เข้าไปมันจะทำให้เราเนี่ยเผ็ด
น้อยลงหรือว่ากินไอศกรีมดื่มนมแต่น้ำ
เปล่าเนี่ยไม่นะคะการดื่มน้ำเปล่ามันจะทำ
ให้ความเผ็ดเนี่ยมันมากขึ้นมากขึ้นนะคะก็
คืออันนี้เป็นวิธีแก้เผ็ดใช่ไหมถ้าเรากิน
อาหารที่เผ็ดๆเราจะทำยังไงให้หายเผ็ดนะคะ
นักเรียนก็ลองดูนะคะถ้านักเรียนคิดว่าอัน
ไหนมันเวิร์ค comment บอกเราได้นะว่าเออ
ผู้หญิงอันนี้ดีทำให้เผ็ดนะคอมเมนต์บอก
ได้นะคะก็วันนี้ครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงจะไปกิน
เผ็ดแล้วนะคะคุณฟ้าจะไปกินส้มตำนะคะเพราะ
ว่าอยากกินนะคะ
ครูฟ้าให้ครูฟ้าไปกินส้มตำก่อนนะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ